hi there internet
i'm john oliver host of last week
tonight we're on break
at the moment but i still wanted to give
you something because i worry that if
people stop paying attention to me
i'll die specifically i wanted to talk
to you about
octopuses not octopi because that's a
latin plural suffix and the word octopus
is derived from greek
the greek plural would be octopies but
that's still not technically correct
because
words adopted into english take an
english plural
suffix which is how we get two octopuses
there now you know how to end a tinder
date in 10 seconds
and before we start i am fully aware
that there are plenty of amazing animals
in the ocean which is as we know
a big wet trash bin full of god's
weirdest typos
there is the pistol shrimp a leggy
little customer with one big claw
that it can snap so powerfully that the
shock wave stuns its prey
yeah it has a gun arm then there is the
wandering meatloaf a lumpy mollusk with
rock-hard teeth and not as the name
suggests
the singer of paradise by the dashboard
light entering a fugue state
but i'm not going to talk about any of
those because i want to talk
about octopuses the subject of among
other things a terrible beatles song
and this year's oscar winner my octopus
teacher a documentary about
an octopus and nothing else of
consequence
and octopus by the way the filmmakers
didn't even bother to thank in their
acceptance speech which is not only a
dick move it's also
concrete proof that octopuses aren't
getting nearly the credit they deserve
it is genuinely confusing to me the
octopuses
aren't the most celebrated animals on
the internet especially when
every fact about them is a hit fact they
have
three hearts they have blue blood they
have beaks
they have massive brains that are
essentially wrapped around their
esophagus yeah that's right
if an octopus swallows a five dollar
foot long it gets a concussion
also did you know they could change
their shape color and texture
because they can take this plant here
for instance oh
i'm just kidding it's a octopus
here is an octopus looking like a rock
then changing its mind
and looking like another plant
unbelievable
and that's not all some of these stealth
bagpipes can go on full
on animorphs the mimic octopus makes
itself
look like a living moving animal so it
pulls all of its arms around behind its
body
and swims along like a poisonous flat
fish called abandoned soul
in other cases if it's getting attacked
it puts six arms down a hole
and raises the other two arms to look
like a poisonous sea snake that has
bands along its body
norman is not always sure exactly what
the mimic is doing
[Music]
he observed this mimic scuttling along
the sea bottom
looking something like a furry turkey
with human legs
yes so left to its own devices the mimic
octopus is hanging out on the bottom of
the ocean
inventing new pet ideas a furry turkey
with human legs
give it to me come on what other animal
has camouflage
close to that chameleons the out of
here
i can see it right there what are you
gonna do chameleon
slowly turn a different shade of green
you're garbage unless hold on
holy it was an octopus the whole
time clever
beautiful clever girl but some octopuses
don't need to morph into other animals
to be impressive some
live an effortlessly majestic life like
the wonderpus
photogenicus seen here absolutely
thriving no exaggeration there's an
octopus called the wonderful
photogenicus
it's hands down the best sequence of
words i have ever come across
there are exactly two things that you
are legally allowed to call that thing
wonder photogenicus and queen both
followed immediately by
can i get you anything here is one fact
about human beings i think about all the
time
none of us are remotely interesting to
look at when we're just existing
the most dynamic looking among us put a
massive amount of work in
just to be borderline presentable but
for the most part we all look like
nothing
just nothing at our absolute best
we're a bunch of tubes just lazily
detailed tubes i hate looking at humans
they're all bad but the wonderpus
photogenicus
strutting gracefully through a group of
garden eels
she's a parade now i know what
you're thinking you're thinking
keep talking about octopuses john you're
doing great i am i will thank you
because
did i mention octopuses are also smart
this octopus learned to take two coconut
halves
and turn itself into a rolling tank two
use
tool use and they're not just smart you
also get the sense that some octopuses
think
we are idiots back in the 1950s
researchers tried to train three
octopuses to pull a lever
in exchange for food two of them did so
but one of them
named charles spent his time in the
study destroying the equipment
and repeatedly squirting the
experimenter with water charles
was a very good octopus and we should be
learning about him in school
we should learn everything about
octopuses because every single fact or
video about them is great
even the weird ones take this deeply
disturbing video
of a man who let a cute small octopus
crawl in and out of his mouth and i
should warn you
the video you're about to see contains
exactly what i just said it does
now is that pleasant to watch no of
course it isn't but
you know who i'm not mad at there the
octopus
that octopus did nothing wrong in fact
the only way that video could have been
improved
is if that man died that is how i feel i
don't have
anything against that indisputably
stupid man i just think that it would be
funny if he went swimming
saw an octopus encourage the octopus to
slide into his dumb mouth
filmed it and then just died forever
i think it would lead to some incredible
conversations uh scuba trevor's funeral
is today he choked on an octopus oh my
god
are you going to sue the restaurant
where it happened it's actually more
complicated than that
based on the information i have so far i
disagree please say more
he was swimming and opened his mouth and
got an octopus to crawl inside and then
he couldn't get the octopus out of his
mouth because octopuses are strong
and also he was using one of his hands
to film the whole thing
okay then i thought i had lots of
questions but it's really just two
uh can i see that footage immediately
and is that hero octopus okay
now thankfully for our purposes that guy
is fine
probably partly because octopuses are
curious and not remotely malevolent
despite
what you might gather from
sensationalized news stories like
geologists beaten up by angriest octopus
on the beach
do you want to see the footage in
question there of course you do here it
is
oh gully yeah
golly indeed now i know that some people
could use videos like that as an
argument that octopuses are jerks but
honestly
if there are two parties on a beach and
one films the other party without
permission
who's being the real jerk there it is
the point of view of this show
and youtube and hbo and whatever massive
mega company currently owns us
that the guy filming that is the jerk
and sends him in for a penny i hope that
man's dead too
i do look there is so much more to know
about octopuses
i didn't even get into the fact that the
giant pacific octopus
has as many as 2 240 suction cups
that can grip objects and also taste you
think
thumbs are such a big deal thumbs
call me when you can taste 2 000 slices
of pizza without getting your mouth
involved you're
idiot but look look america and
to some extent the world all i've been
trying to say in this piece and in a way
my entire life is that octopuses are
cool
cats have dominated the internet for far
too long and it is past
time the octopuses get their turn that's
it
that's my whole argument here octopuses
are great
i don't have some big call to action i'm
not going to bring out
a giant octopus mascot although
that is a good idea i should get on that
instead
i just hope that this video helped you
appreciate octopuses a little more than
you did when it started
thank you so much for watching we'll be
back july 25th unless
i get murdered by an octopus before then
and god
i hope so bye